way better feel that your opponent today
brings a little bit of all or nothing
i i don't know i
only played him once so i don't really
know his style yet
look forward to seeing you playing your
game level thank
you it was a loss for levon aronian in
game one against hans niemann and it was
a loss for magnus carlsen in game one
against ali reza russia now with the
white pieces magnus carlsen is this
looking better after only one move
so far but it's about how magnus focuses
i feel in this game whether he can avoid
those kind of external thoughts and uh
laughing in general we love to see it
but not maybe throughout the entire game
so he does start with the english
opening magnus and then
after a bit of thought he brings his
knight out so this could transpose into
a variety of openings it could transpose
to the queen's gambit the catalan
okay this is still well-known stuff
magnus now will push one of the white
pawns in the center
and okay still much more steady at least
than the last game in terms of the
opening magnus though he's back at his
old tricks laughing again he captures a
pawn
trading off here and a ver a variation
at least of the queen's gambit declined
uh still well-known stuff but not
supposed to be the most critical
yeah
my understanding is that it's not
critical at all and that's uh all
alireza has to do with the black pieces
is just support the center and then this
is the problem the light squared bishop
that black has will manage to get
outside the pawn chain
just a very solid start it feels like
magnus today he's just trying to try to
avoid any theoretical battles where it's
about homework
it's about who's kind of prepared harder
but it also feels like he's freestyling
and that's dangerous and speech us in
longer games you can get away with with
freestyling at the critical moments you
stop you pause you kind of pull yourself
back from the brink but in rapid chess
whenever i feed styled it tends to go a
bit wrong um
i mean he's just smiling it looking away
from the screen again
just kind of choosing his move according
to his mood and
that's a dangerous game
what do you guys think of this uh
opening choice do you think it this
kind of strategy behind it will favor
magnus later on it will become a slower
game at least
uh no immediate fireworks
yeah i think it makes sense i mean uh
ferruccia is a very dangerous attacking
player tactical player so i think fixing
the pawn structure makes does make a lot
of sense
um but i know i'm still i'm still a bit
bewildered um it'd be interesting to see
the quality of his play in this game to
be entirely honest
um this is this is one of the main ideas
here and um this this tries to stop
black developing the light square bishop
to the normal square but
this line is supposed to be equal but
magnus often doesn't mind that i mean he
often plays positions where he which are
equal as long as he enjoys playing the
middle game structures and i think
that's a lesson to take you know
everyone should take home you don't
always have to play an opening to get an
advantage you can play openings that
just get you positions you enjoy playing
uh so i think the main move here is to
try and develop well as many moves here
but it's it's quite yeah early days so
far uh but i i've he must be listening
to a podcast and i really want to know
what podcast he's listening to
he's obviously pretty funny
um and i need to get myself some of that
podcast
whatever he's on i
kind of i want some of it
so
um that's been one of the good night
episodes
which one is the funniest one though i'm
not sure that he would be allowed to
listen to a chest we've had some funny
podcasts in the past with gary with
jordan first
yeah yeah with eric hansen a few others
yeah it could be could be listening to
you simon maybe it's the podcast we did
with you
once again it must be
maybe maybe
yeah i'm i'm surprised i did like that
tweet early on that we saw from tricky
dicky saying can magnus laugh his way to
one out of one and
this is the major move where black
simply
just forces that bishop to come to the
f5 square
and uh
yeah very natural developing move from
magnus
and uh yeah i'm kind of curious what is
everyone thinking about uh
magnus ali reza who are you cheering for
who you want
who how are you supporting your
favorites and remember there's a selfie
competition going on it's a selfie
competition so we do like to see
pictures in landscape mode and remember
to tweet us using the hashtag
chesschamps how are you cheering for
your favorite player yeah
and we're especially big fans of four
fingers just so you know
haven't seen any so far i know i haven't
seen any yet but you guys
there i mean our viewers at home that
are just so creative
they will
just blow our minds i should have
brought mine uh i have two phone fingers
yeah whenever i go to sports in the us i
buy foam fingers
do you have any with magnus on it no i
have new york rangers and uh chicago
balls are they [ __ ] yeah yeah
no i haven't found any chess ones but uh
you must make them
yeah yeah definitely next time for the
tour the last major and if it's an
in-person event we can
have those
fans with foam fingers
or even be like pieces
yeah
yeah yeah queen we might get ones with
david yeah depending
on what happens potentially just to make
you more nervous david
sorry
no pressure
for anyone who is joining us late in
this tournament uh earlier we were
celebrating david's incredible gold
medal in the chess olympiad
and uh doing so
uh our tour director challenged david to
and invited him to play in a meltwater
championship tournament
and david will think about it i mean if
magnus promises to play like he did in
the first game against me
then i'll say yes definitely but
um yeah it's a
lot of preparation too to become one of
the strong players like these or even to
challenge some of the uh these guys
they're they all work so hard many hours
a day with big teams behind them it's
yeah
it's their job right this is what they
do yeah all day every day prepare yeah i
think people forget like just how much
preparation you have to do yeah to to
compete at this level i mean it's it's
hours every day i mean you're talking
five six hours preparation most of the
time you know maybe more for some of the
younger guys day day in day out then you
have to play you have to be in the right
mind there's so many things that go on
just to get them into this position and
that's for decades you know you do that
so it's hard work playing
so uh yeah it's not just turn up and you
know bang out some moves on the
chessboard it doesn't work that way um
and yeah i mean the game the way the
game's going it all seems pretty pretty
sensible at the moment i mean uh
this this is one this is one pawn
structure
that i think every chess player should
know right david i mean this this is uh
one pawn structure if you play the
queen's pawn uh or move one you're very
likely to get at some point in your
chess career and what are the sort of
main ideas here david yeah so this pawn
structure is called the carlsbad
structure um there's actually a lot of
material out there if you want to
research it's when one side has a
structure like this pointing towards the
center and the other side uh kind of has
the same but
kind of on the other flank and
this just means that i both sides want
to play on different sides of the board
quite usually and there are ideas for
example uh something we call a minority
attack where whites two later march
forward to kind of destabilize these
three you could imagine a scenario where
not right now but later white supports
this pawn pushing forward push on again
maybe a capture and you weaken black
structure in the process
there are often ideas as well of white
stepping forward in the center this is
counter-intuitive perhaps because white
will end up um say black plays a move
white will end up with a isolated pawn
in the middle but a lot of open lines in
the center it's not clear who this
favors that's uh often in the air too
uh but in general it's just about
maneuvering and it's about whose pieces
will be more ready uh when the action
finally does start whether it's this
pawn push this pawn push black often
tries to
um
again very hard to show but if black
could
say here castle and uh
let's say both sides castle their kings
if black could
plant a knight in the middle of the
board maybe then black has great control
this is one of black's most common ideas
black tries to play on the king side in
general if we go back to the current
position because his pawns are pointing
this way and white plays on the queen
side usually because white pawns point
in this direction there's plenty of
plans it takes a lifetime to master
these types of things but uh meanwhile
while alireza ferruccia is thinking it
looks like magnus back to us
back to his laughter
yeah
that podcast that he's listening to yeah
it's hilarious i know you want to know
whatever it is
is it uh should we be a little bit
critical of this magnus carlsen he's in
the lead in the tournament he's fighting
to win it so much at stake and he comes
back yeah totally i mean it's
bewildering especially in light of the
first game where he did not play up to
his normal level yeah and uh okay here
it's a normal game so far
and uh it's up to the game is going to
develop very classically as david
indicated and yeah okay he's smiling
so it's not a it's not a crime
no in that way if you have to laugh you
have to lie obviously but if you have to
put yourself in a good mood but is it is
he laughing again i mean he's obviously
not focused yeah it depends on how this
game goes if if it follows the same
trend of the last game where he clearly
loses
kind of
loses all
focus on the game if it leads to
mistakes leads to blunders leads to
getting outplayed again then it's clear
what the cause is
and you can't you can't play proper
chess if you're in that kind of mode i
mean magnus has really talented the
world champion so he can he can still
play a great game but you can't play
your best if you're not concentrated
fully it's just like it's impossible
right it doesn't matter if you're
laughing or you're crying or something
you just can't you've got you've got to
be chess is a really hard game i mean
like you know i i you know
it's it's so that's why it's a bit
buildering yeah i think you know and
obviously an over-the-board chest this
would be unheard of your opponent is
sitting a meter away from you you cannot
be laughing here they have a computer in
between them but is it somewhat
disrespectful to
alareza ruja will he
feel that i mean as long as he's not in
his direct eye line i don't think it
would be too distracting for ferugia and
i know magnus for sure doesn't mean any
offense there's a lot of mutual respect
between these two players
i think magnus is just kind of in his
own little zone right now and he's not
worried about the opponents he's not
worried about too much
um but yeah i mean personally i mean if
i do end up taking up that invitation to
play in the tour i don't think i'll be
listening to any music any podcast at
all because it's just a distraction it's
not that long to have to concentrate
each game both players only have 15
minutes it's half an hour
that's enough to focus these plays have
been doing their whole lives it must be
a podcast right i mean just something i
think we you know we're mentioning this
a lot because we've never seen it before
uh you know we've played we've played uh
you know decades of chess in tournaments
and we've never seen it so it is kind of
like
new and it's like what the hell's going
on
why is this going on and
you know back to the chest i i i you
know not much to my eyes has changed
black should be absolutely comfortable
uh but you know pretty even still i
guess the position uh at this moment in
time yeah do you look at the way he was
blinking there he's definitely listening
to something where he's having to
actually process stuff it's not music
where you can kind of still
kind of just have it on in the
background and then you you kind of
calculate you still
kind of working out the chess moves it's
it's definitely kind of the slow
blinking there and then occasional fast
blinking he's listening kind of taking
in information probably it is a podcast
after all yeah and
yeah i mean we need to find out what
this is because definitely it's clearly
affecting uh what it did affect his
chest in the last game be good to see
his uh spotify list because obviously
the players are allowed to listen to
music and i'm just really intrigued now
to know what he's listening to
uh with black's last move this seems
like a good move david
i mean it's all about maneuvering the
pieces to the best squares uh black's
gonna try to get his king safe but that
knight seems to be on quite a good quite
a good uh track there i suppose to to to
improve itself
it's i mean i'm not critical of what
aloreza is doing but i do find it
slightly odd because my understanding of
these kind of particular positions and i
played them a lot from the black side is
that you do really want a knight on the
dream square of d6
if you can get that knight there and
and in this particular position where
the light square bishops have been
swapped off it's sometimes really good
to actually expand as far as you can on
the left side the left side of the board
and secure the c4 square
so
that is whenever i played it that seemed
that is the optimal setup that i found
right so why does that secure the c4
square
because you're basically controlling all
the squares all the pawn pushes around
it let's say
we give each side a few moves yeah
yeah if black can somehow it takes a
while it's not easy to show on the board
but if for example the knight could come
round let's say white continues waiting
if white's not if the black knight ends
up on the square this is uh i guess your
idea ivanka yeah um this pawn means that
you control this square white can never
push his own pawn forward to kind of
challenge the black knight this pawn is
a backward pawn black's knight kind of
sits here he's not quite an outpost
because eventually it might get kicked
away but it's basically an outpost
defended anchored by its own pawn and it
sits in white's half it's very annoying
staring at a pawn itself
so i've had this plan done to me by two
uh
oh
one very very strong woman grand masters
actually uh humpy canary and maria
mazzychick
and i i was really struggling with the
white pieces so this is if we go back to
the position so this is my for me my
dream position for the black pieces if
you take a look at that night it's as
david indicated it's going to take an
age
gonna
take such a long time to get it to the
d6 square which is the beautiful square
yeah that being said this type of
position there are dozens of different
plans um i mean one is uh was just
pointed out by ivanka here but i guess
uh his idea is to just challenge this
bishop and when for example it steps
back uh he just wants to get his king
castled he just wants to maybe off trade
off these bishops long term and there's
nothing too scary that can happen to
black here the centre is closed after
all both sides have uh
reasons to be happy i mean black will
happily castle say white kind of
initiates this type of thing
black can still go for this plan later
advancing pawns black can still trade
off these bishops he can still maneuver
his knight back to the center kind of uh
aim for another nice outpost for knight
another quite traditional one
as simon mentions there's plans for both
sides it's just about maneuvering
there's not going to be any direct
attacks anytime soon most likely
unless magnus kind of
is listening to a really aggressive
podcast and wants to
do something a bit fruity but yeah the
play will slow down for the next few
moves before
any more kind of entertaining fireworks
so
uh personally i quite like it this is a
decent square for the night
traditionally in these types of systems
uh especially if you want to end up
playing on the king side on the right
half of the wood but magnus he's slowed
down he's been thinking for nearly five
minutes now
i mean it looks like there's a bunch of
obvious moves while i was gonna i was
gonna say any move other than this one
at first i thought he might kick back
this night
uh this is maybe the most obvious move
in the position kick your opponent's
pieces outside uh out of your heart for
the board also you could just castle on
this flank but magnus
yeah harry the age point marching up
yeah yeah hello harry i mean
it seems a bit strange to
not move that pawn one square first if
you're gonna push the h pawn then maybe
you can kick away black's knight first i
i don't like having pieces of my own
half of the board and a good good bit of
advice is you know someone does move a
piece into your half of the board like
that black knight is in white's half
give it a kick you know give it a little
kick away so
i do love pushing the h pawn and this
move is clearly aimed against black's
formation or his pawn formation on the
king side he's trying to he's trying to
uh attack that but the black knight
seems to now be
anchored there
on quite a dangerous square so uh i also
think where where's where's the white
king gonna go now and black just stops
that pawn from going any any further
forwards now yeah the reason i'm so
surprised is uh as you mentioned simon
this knight is kind of uh cemented on a
really nice square for a while but also
white has taken away the opportunity to
castle himself it's going to be really
uh tricky now for the white king to
castle because this pawn uh you just
have to always worry about it suddenly
the white king will not be safe on this
flank magnus he does have ambitious
intentions however he instead of
castling uh brings his knight forward so
he's stopping the black knight from
jumping to the square at one to two and
uh now he's arguing that his knight is
perhaps just as strong as this black
piece actually he wants to kick away
this black knight by pushing his f pawn
forward instead
i don't think we will see a bishop
capture on this square because actually
this would
trap the black knight behind enemy lines
the black knight now has no escape
squares it will simply fall off the
board after it's kicked away by a pawn
next move so a small trap as well from
magnus and uh there's definitely
there's definitely some idea uh behind
what he's doing he wants to kick away
this black knight for example again if
black does nothing he'll kick away this
knight and then i guess he wants to
castle the long way and start opening
the center while the black king
is yet uncastled
interesting stuff i quite like it it's
creative and
creative in a good way at least compared
to what he did in the previous game
magnus
yeah ferocious now with some questions
to answer yeah
all right well it's not a must-win
situation for magnus but he has to win
uh at least one game uh today to take it
to tie breaks and this is so interesting
on the tournament standings you guys
purusha before this game is two points
behind
magnus carlsen if he wins this in the
rapid portion he will be ahead of magnus
heading into the final day in the
tournament and of course we're keeping
close eye on pragnanda today as well
playing against young christoph duda
duda who won his match in blitz
yesterday to magnus carlsen and pride
today
he lost the first game to young
christophe duda he is
currently
playing game two keeping a very close
eye on that as well
magnus carlsen he keeps
smiling in this game but it is for ruja
and the move and foruja obviously with
the black pieces and in the lead he's
going to be very happy with a draw in
this game yeah farouza would love a draw
right now um we did mention we saw those
stats just before the show farouza with
black not doing that well this
tournament yeah and uh whenever i faced
him or prepared for him i've always
noticed he's significantly scarier with
white with white he just always gets his
type of position um i guess that's like
having the servant tennis you can always
kind of plant it on a spot you want you
can kind of force your opponent into a
certain type of position
but with black somehow yeah he's he
ferocious style his attitude is to
always push um it was said that he tries
to take the draw out of the equation he
doesn't want to play anything simple
doesn't want to play any boring end
games and with black it's hard to avoid
that type of thing sometimes
and uh yeah we'll see whether the color
situation here favors magnus in this
game ferruccia ticking down to six
minutes on the clock as he makes his uh
move are you surprised by any
just improving the black queen very
sensible so we're gonna go down to miami
again and uh minus carlson in a very
good mood
in uh
the tournament so far today tanya how is
the mood with the spectators
it's pretty dense actually and
everyone's really surprised with
magnus's expression throughout i mean
the games are really not going his way
but the thing is we know magnus uh i
think he is sort of just amused by how
badly he's playing today but he's got to
get that
uh he's got to change that narrative
because he's got three big games one is
going on and of course he's in the lead
and he could potentially lose out we've
got a mother and a son duo with us
who've traveled to watch the tournament
hey guys hi thank you my name is vivi
and this is oliver and
oliver are you having fun here um yeah
i'm looking forward to playing some
games like right over there
yeah and i'm also looking forward to
having a lot of fun in here too yeah do
you have a favorite player
our favorite what favorite player
um what do you like
oh a food no player oh player magnus
carlsen yeah
i'm nervous
i've got to ask you can you make
anything out of magnus's expressions in
there i don't know we are excited to see
him so i hope he sees that the fans are
here and we are here here for him that's
our favorite
we also
are also like in giri we're locals from
a us where i'm also
from ecuador by my little flag so um i
mean we're cheering from the for the us
players but
for hans but
but magnus is our favorite definition
have you been watching the hans
interviews uh well i know he no yeah i
mean we want to cheer for the locals but
yeah
not
they are people too so they lose games
it gets into them i don't like the
comments but i mean
like i said i'm glad that magnus is in a
good mood because he's very excited to
try to meet him today
lots of fans here kaya and as they're
saying that you know bad days happen
well magnus looks like things are not
going his way so far talk to you guys in
the studio absolutely thank you so much
uh tanya
nice to hear that the spectators are
enjoying magnus's mood today laughing a
lot also in this game
and uh we had some moves david yeah
we've had some moves both sides had
nights in the opposition's half and both
of those knights have been kicked back
but more importantly white has castled
first white has committed his king now
to this left side of the board the white
king is very safe there
so it makes a lot of sense and magnus
he's ready to start stepping pawns
forward in the center as white
it feels like ferruga's position is a
bit loose black's king has to decide as
well what it wants to do is black's king
really going to castle over to the right
side of the board where there are some
loose pawns you need to get your knight
out the way first of course if the black
king copies the white king
maybe it's not as safe as it can as its
counterpart there
i really don't like the
the black pawn formation on this right
half it just feels
very tender it feels like the black
knights will be tied down defending for
quite a while
and uh whose position do you prefer here
guys just as the evaluation bar shoots
up
yeah i like what magnus is doing to be
honest with you i mean it has it looks
very natural white's pieces are well
placed and the plan straightforward easy
stuff push forward in the center yeah
it's now the moment do you think would
you go for it now while the black king's
in the middle or would you still build
up i guess white's rook could be
improved in the corner white king could
shuffle across that's normally a good
idea in these types of positions
now or
wait
big question
yeah i'd probably play it now um just
the black king's in the middle right so
why don't we open a line towards blank's
king um i don't see any reason to wait
here
i mean you can build up but if your
opponent's kings in the middle you want
to open up um and
probably want to open it up before the
podcast is over or saying you know get
it done get the business uh
sealed but i think this is much more
magnus like uh what's happening here
it's been impressive so far yeah it came
from magnus very impressive i mean just
the way the pieces have moved and this
this
move of the h pawn was actually probably
the start of this great plan because
just look at black's pieces
ali razer hasn't managed to get that
knight next to his king ever into the
game now um and i don't know where he's
going to put his king i mean i really
don't like the idea of castling queen
side and
this is this is going much better for
magnus this game more more magnus style
so yeah like things that just tangled up
for for those two black knights look
horrible and okay he does capture maybe
he had to and white takes back with the
queen uh usually we would want to take
back with the pawn but this is the more
direct attempt like you said simon the
black king is in the middle
why not play with pieces rather than
pawns yeah yeah you've got an open file
put a rook on the open file next and
just line them up against black's king
the section plays itself yeah it does
and
if black doesn't castle then uh ferozia
is just going to
sorry if uh black doesn't castle magnus
is simply going to explode open the
center by pushing the d pawn forward
and uh
do it anyway yeah he's uh smiling
so i mean he keeps on laughing and i
think it's quite nice to see good mood
and uh talking about good mood
whilst ali reza is thinking about how to
continue can i share with you a few
selfies of how everyone is cheering for
their favorite
players we have abhishek who's cheering
with their budgie with some soothing
music whilst watching the ftx crypto cup
apparently the budgie is very interested
in chess and music aha and uh zero
blunders is actually cheering for hands
it says when you play with hands you get
no chance so take your seats and order
some oobies
very nice
and finally just uh my last one
bob bryan american tennis player sends a
selfie and says let's go partner
remember they partnered under he
partnered up with ali reza fuja to win
the pairs cup yep the celebrity uh cup
hand and brain that is so cool bob bryan
following the action rooting for elereza
so cool i i've watched so many matches
of the brian brothers
yeah super cool yeah
experts in double tennis fantastic we're
excited to have you guys follow we can
see lavon aronian getting up that must
mean his second game here is over and
what happened in that one it's a win for
levon against hans neiman a comeback
they are now tied the two americans
after two games
and if i quick win here for lavon yeah
they're just trading blows in that one
niemann won in really brutal style the
first game now aronian just crushed his
younger opponent so 1-1 and
hard to predict that match up and in
this one the bar is now all the way over
to magnus carlsen's side with the white
pieces
in a comeback situation here losing game
one
much better game by him then i guess
this one and the clocks ticking down to
two minutes for ferruccia
yeah it's looking very uh difficult now
for furuja it's actually a bit of a
mirror image if you look at the pawn
structure especially on the left uh the
left half of the board we had this exact
same pawn structure in the previous game
between these two where farouza was
white and one very nicely
it's literally the exact same pawn
structure on the left half
and uh same problems for black as magnus
experienced in the last game black's
king how does it get across to safety
black's king is cut off look at the
white bishop
just kind of staring down that diagonal
on the dark squares towards the black
king white's queen lurking nearby
do you guys see a defense here for
frugia um or kind of maybe now or over
the next few moves it's going to be an
uphill struggle right yeah i mean uh i i
think white's white's just been
dominating this match so far uh ferruta
won the first game very easily and um i
think now well i think this is probably
a pawn sacrifice here um for example
magnus can simply just take that bishop
and the pawn in front of the white queen
will most likely drop
um it just looks really bad for fruition
this one he was never able to get his
king safe and
you know that's one of the one of the
things you need to do in chess right you
need to control the center get your
pieces out and get your king safe and he
he kind of messed around a little bit
too much with some unnecessary pawn
moves maybe as well that's another
little error that is quite common
without getting his king well i mean the
king on the queen side is just it's just
not safe is it at all there with white's
pieces and that white pawn in the middle
of the ball being so dominant
so uh it looks all one-way traffic for
magnus here yeah this i mean this looks
very strong but i don't know i would be
reluctant to go for this pawn
immediately because at least now the
black king is
relatively safe at least now there might
be some ideas of black trying to attack
uh with his rook still great for white
of course with this massive extra pawn
your knight coming in if this black
knight was somewhere else maybe
some small chances but in the current
position um if we go back
yeah somehow it just feels like uh for
ruja he's hoping that we go magnus
doesn't take he was hoping to give up a
pawn just to survive magnus is going for
more uh he's saying okay i'm going to
try and get this pawn anyway but i'm
also putting pressure on your bishop and
now there might be a bishop trade but
it's going to be on white's terms and we
could see the same scenario essentially
if the bishops disappear but white will
win this pawn but look the black knights
are even worse than in that last
variation magnus i think he's playing
super well right now
and this has been a good game it's good
to see him back playing so clearly
clearly
he's uh on form in this one and he's
played some very clever ideas
and got a winning position
easily really very easily i like the
fact that he's kind of taken this
relatively harmless opening variation
and just
injected some venom into it and the
position that he's got is just fabulous
i mean your support for choice i'm not
sure i would take this pawn right now uh
just because it would walk into uh
potentially something on the open file
later on but uh okay i was gonna say
maybe this pawn is up for grabs i
couldn't see a reason why you can't grab
this pawn magnus says okay i'm not even
tempted i'm not going to be greedy i'm
just going to improve my worst place
piece that rook i mean these pieces are
just perfectly centralized for white as
soon as you get this white knight in the
game as soon as you kind of force a
capture of also trade on the square
which has just happened all of white's
pieces are perfectly centralized
perfectly active these pieces for black
are just terrible
and uh still a couple of pawns attacked
farouza though fighting bringing his
knight forward the white queen
threatened i guess you'll drop back you
don't want to take a pawn because you
walk into a nasty pin
but uh
yeah i mean wherever you go as long as
you go to a safe square with white say
this one
lining up on a nice diagonal it looks
very very strong
for rouge upping the pace though down to
one minute
and
yeah it still looks like a glorious
position for white magnus just needs to
stabilize which he does by defending his
knights two great pieces and
it's the world champions game to lose
now
looking good i think we all prefer
white's position black's king is far
weaker than its counterpart
and black's pawns not looking great
either
what else to say it's been magnus in top
form this is typical magnus if you
hadn't shown us pictures of him laughing
i would say this is just a great game
so smooth full focus
yeah he's i mean now he's cashing in
here so you have to cash in at some
point your positional advantages and
change them to a to a tactical advantage
and by by taking issue you when you win
a safe pawn because black's knight in
the middle is now destabilized and you
you can win that night any moment so
yeah so typical magnus it seems like
magnus is back and this is great so it's
going to be one all right which is what
we want really we want a close match and
and white is dominating so um foruga
with white in the next round is he is he
gonna would you guys reckon is he gonna
uh just roll it out again and smash up
magnus is he going to do the business i
mean it's funny sometimes we look at the
stats right and we say okay there's
reasons for this certain pattern it's
not going to happen in this game but
we looked at the stats before today we
said ferrucc is great with white
struggles a bit with black
that's just happened um
sometimes the players they forget to
look at the stats they're too busy
looking at the moves when they prepare
openings i've been guilty of that myself
but uh yeah magnus needs to play solid
for the next game that's all i know yeah
foruger will go on the attack he'll do
his own thing but and it does seem for
frugal like one one thing that could
automatically like improve his game he's
trying to
fix his openings a little bit with the
black pieces because he didn't really
get the kind i mean playing the queen's
gambit doesn't really seem to fit him i
mean you've got to try to play openings
that excel your natural talents so you
know um so i'm surprised you know he
he's playing that opening basically
maybe he could try something else yeah
there are more active openings that are
still solid enough uh that he could
choose and ferocious problem his whole
career he played really aggressively as
black because he played lots of open
tournaments where you need to win with
black now he's playing the top guys he's
still quite young
just adding that solidity maybe
something like yan upon issue just
adding the petrol for adding the berlin
or something uh solid
yeah that might help him make that final
step yeah you guys talking about solid
and ferrucious position here's anything
but solid i mean just look at the white
rook on the seventh row it's going to be
reinforced by its sibling standing there
on d1
the queen can come in as well
i mean the position is just creaking for
ferugia something is going to give
yeah white's a pawn up and he has the
positional
advantages and okay trade one set of
rooks doesn't really help
what can you even move for black here
you can barely move the black knight the
black queen doesn't have any decent
squares really the black rook is tied
down defending the black knight
yeah i mean the big thing is that the
black queen has got no active
possibilities at all
and uh okay i mean i i like this move by
ferugia but unfortunately it's
insufficient yeah look at this classic
magnus he's back to his old self back to
his uh
back to top form simply he swaps the
queens heads into an end game where he
can just grind it out with his extra
pawn you don't really need to grind this
one out to be honest because black's
pawns on the right half of the board
they're just too weak they're both going
to drop off
sooner or later
35 seconds and uh for rouge's position
is so difficult
you know what i would do here simon in
this position he's resigned he has
resigned sorry david he got it first
yeah
i would resign
but magnus takes the win an important
one wow
this is interesting you guys magnus
carlsen ties the match against ali reza
frugia in 25 minutes game three will
start all the reservation we'll have the
white pieces and i will not looking
happy the young frenchman obviously
losing
this game too against the magnus magnus
has looked happy the entire day now he
must be very happy an important comeback
in
the match and i really hope he will stop
for a comment in miami
let's see when he walks towards uh